hello and welcome to Rochford district
matters the magazine produced by the
council for its residence this is the
winter 2015 edition in this edition our
articles on your Christmas and New Year
refuse collections family theater shows
the budget survey out and about sports
awards for 2015 how to stay well this
winter and much more but we'll start
with Rochford's preparations for the
winter weather winter in rockford it's
set to be the coldest winter for five
years with 36 days of snow expected over
the winter season while most is forecast
to fall in Scotland there's a good
chance that Rochford will see some
frosty mornings and flutters of snow to
weather forecasters say the temperatures
could even drop to minus 16 degrees with
the coldest Atlantic temperatures
expected since records began 80 years
ago the weather is expected to blanket
the UK Rochford District Council will
monitor all weather forecasts and keep
residents up to date on its Rochford
District Council Facebook page and
website let it snow rochford district
council is prepared for snow this winter
with two new Schmidt sweeper machines
that have snow brushes and grit boxes
the vehicles have been prepped and are
ready to tackle the harsh winter
forecast should it prove to be as
predicted with snow and plunging
temperatures gritting overall is
undertaken by essex county council
although Rochford district council
undertakes the gritting of the car parks
as and when required despite forecasts
of a potential salt shortage if the cold
snowy blast does happen our DC has
plenty of tons stored away ready for use
the biggest potential problem can be
severe ice which can prevent the refuse
vehicles managing the steeper roads
which become hazardously slippery
photography competition with the
Rochford district featuring ancient
woodlands marshland coast and ste
landscapes wallasey Island foul ness
fields and wildlife
residents are invited to take photos of
what winter in rochford may mean to them
the chairman of Rochford District
Council Councillor Heather Glynn will
judge the competition there will be a
prize and certificate for each winner
from two categories the first under-18s
and the second adult the categories are
winter in rochford animal stroke pet
stroke people stroke birds under-18s and
adult landscapes seen under 18s and
adult general under 18s and adult please
email your entry to communications at
Rochford gov UK by entering the
competition the applicant agrees to
their photos being used by Rochford
district council please state your name
age address phone number and location
for your photo good luck keep an eye on
Facebook for winter in rockford photos
every day christmas and new year
collection days some collection days
will change here are the details for
Monday the 21st of December through to
thursday the 24th of december normal
collections for recyclables and
compostables friday the twenty-fifth of
december will change to tuesday the 29th
recyclables only monday the
twenty-eighth of december and tuesday
the 29th of december will be one day
later for non-recyclables only wednesday
the 30th and thursday the 31st of
december will be as normal for
non-recyclables only and friday the
first of January will be Saturday the
second of January for non-recyclables
only many of you may choose to have real
christmas trees this year if so you'll
be able to dispose of them by cutting
them down and placing them in your
compostables bin please be aware that we
can only accept accept trunks or
branches which are less than 30
centimeters in diameter and all
decorations should be removed before
all the tree is placed in the
compostables bin for anything larger
please take them to the recycling center
for household waste in Castle Road
rayleigh the recycling is for life not
just for Christmas recycling is an
excellent way of saving energy and
conserving the environment did you know
that one recycled tin can would save
enough energy to power a television for
three hours one recycled glass bottle
would save enough energy to power a
computer for 25 minutes one recycled
plastic bottle would save enough energy
to power a 60-watt light bulb for three
hours seventy percent less energy is
required to recycle paper compared with
making it from raw materials if just one
aluminium air freshner aerosol is rice
recycled by everyone in the UK enough
energy could be saved to vacuum over
eight hundred and seventy six thousand
homes for a year we want your old
clothing and electricals did Santa bring
you new socks and slippers for Christmas
was there a new hair dryer or mobile
phone under your Christmas tree many of
you will have a big sort out after
Christmas to make way for the new
clothes and electrical items you
received so please remember that you can
reuse and recycle most of these
throughout the district the council
office operates a curbside scheme for
reusable textiles including clothes
shoes handbags belts and hats which can
be placed into a special blue sack and
left out for collection on your
recyclables collection day next to your
recyclables bin please do not place
these items into any of your bins blue
sacks can be ordered free of charge by
contacting Essex tectiles on 800 787
9071 you can also call this number if
you want to book a collection service
from them if you have lots of items and
would prefer not to leave them with your
bin there are also a number of textile
recycling banks located around the
district any small electrical items
which use a plug including kettles
toasters shavers tablets
electric toothbrushes straighteners
cables plugs and charges which are no
longer needed or are broken can be
recycled at the electricals recycling
bank located in back lane car park in
rockford you can also take them to the
recycling center for household waste in
Castle Road raley remember it is always
better to try and reuse items first so
if they are in good working order then
you may be able to give them to someone
else so they can enjoy a second life
hundreds of tons of clothing and
electrical items still end up in
landfill in the UK every year despite
the fact that there are plenty of
opportunities to reuse and recycle them
please make a difference this Christmas
for further information on what can be
recycled in the Rochford district visit
our website w WH for guru K /recycling
hedgehogs for the kids hedgehogs have
declined in Britain as fast as Tigers
have worldwide and so there is a big
push for homeowners to help the prickly
creatures this winter autumn sees the
rise of autumn juveniles these are the
young hedgehogs born now old enough to
be away from their mum but too young to
hibernate as a hedgehog needs to weigh
at least one pound to hibernate
effectively great care needs to be taken
to protect the autumn juveniles who may
not have grown enough to hibernate the
British head hoe Preservation Society
has lots of tips on how to make your
garden hedgehog friendly and what to do
if you find a hedgehog ww British
hedgehogs co uk and some interesting
facts about hedgehogs did you know a
hedgehog can have 5,000 spines a spine
lasts a year before falling out and the
creature growing a replacement there are
17 species of Hedgehog between 111
babies can be born in any litter the
proper name for a hedgehog is air in ace
o-- morphia a hedgehog can travel two
miles in a night
a message from counselor heather glen
chairman of Rochford district council
christmas is here once again and
whatever your circumstances are i wish
you a very peaceful time and happy
memories to take into the new year thank
you for inviting me to join you in your
various events throughout the year
across the Rockford district from the
wildwoods day the 100 mile walk along
both sides of the river crouch to join
the various schools on each side of the
river in friendship the opening of the
RSPB wetlands at wallasey island and
most of all the invitations to visit
clubs schools and such a variety of
groups right across the district it's so
very interesting to spend my time with
each of you and I look forward to
meeting many more of you in the coming
months Thank You Heather a volunteer
celebration on friday the 9th of october
oxford district council rewarded its
hard working team of volunteers with a
coach trip to the museum of power in
langdon the museum set in four acres of
beautiful gardens and grounds is home to
Marshall a triple expansion steam
pumping engine believed to be the last
one built by the lilleshall company and
possibly the last remaining fully
functional steam pumping engine in the
world the trip began with refreshments
and cake in the beautiful steam pump Tea
Room and ended in the Astoria model
village rochford District Council's
leisure team organized a volunteer
celebration event every year which in
the past has seen them visiting stow
maries aerodrome in that stone Hall and
even the houses of parliament the trips
are a way of saying thank you to the
volunteers for their hard work and
dedication throughout the year the group
is made up of rayleigh windmill health
walk parkrun and active Rochford
volunteers the leisure team would like
to take this opportunity to extend a big
thank you to all of the volunteers for
giving up their time to the rayleigh
windmill health walks parkrun and active
Rochford projects all of which would not
run without them their passion and
dedication is greatly valued and
appreciated volunteer at
windmill Raider windmill opens from
april to September every Wednesday
Saturday and Sunday volunteers work as
little or often as they can and help
with a number of areas such as running
the museum giving guided tours greeting
visitors on arrival and helping children
dress up in period costumes on the
ground floor rainy windmill boasts an
award-winning team of volunteers and
would love to hear from anyone who would
be interested in joining them for more
information please email leisure at
Rochford gov you k Rockford and Castle
Point health walk volunteers weekly
walks take place in both the Rockford
district and borough of Castle Point led
by trained walk leaders the short walks
are a great way to get and stay healthy
explore what's on your doorstep and make
new friends we are always looking for
new volunteers to support the walks even
if you can't commit to every week we
would still love to hear from you
contact the loser team on 0 1 702 318
one-to-one or email leisure at Rochford
gov you k and parkrun hockley woods park
run started in February 2015 the five
kilometres Saturday morning run
regularly sees 150 plus runners enjoying
the beautiful and ever-changing hockley
woods every Park run only happens
because of the time and dedication of
our volunteers many thanks to all of
them past and present we are always
looking for new volunteers for more
information on how to get involved
please go to ww parkrun or guk forward
slash hockley woods forward slash
volunteer family theater shows at the
mill and arts & Events Center
professional theater shows for younger
children and their families take place
at the mill and arts events center in
rayleigh the program runs monthly during
term time and all the shows are fun
entertaining and affordable with all
tickets priced at four pounds we are
very pleased to announce details for
spring 2016 and
you and your family will continue to
enjoy the range of theater and puppetry
on offer once again we have put together
a program featuring familiar stories
alongside original tales presented to
you by some of the best small-scale
theater companies across the oka UK the
family theater program has been arranged
by Rochford District Council leisure
working with fusion lifestyle fly away
Katy Sunday the 17th of January 2016 11
a.m. & 2pm long nose puppets recommended
age to 27 years running time 40 minutes
fly away Katy is an inspiring flight of
fancy about the power of the imagination
based on the popular children's book by
Polly Dunbar with music by Tom gray of
Gomez katie is all alone feeling gray
the birds in the picture are on her wall
looks so colorful if only Katie could be
as bright as them who knows what might
happen the show is bursting with color
movement and surprises with puppets of
various scales acting the story lullaby
Lane sunday the twenty-first of februari
2016 at 2pm Halfmoon presents
recommended age three to six years
running time 45 minutes join Katie as
she returns to her childhood home on
lullaby Lane in search of Forgotten
friends much love toys and the special
gift of music making her dad gave her as
Katie's childhood memories come to life
we meet her neighbors who live behind
the brightly colored doors on her street
pulsating with the energy of a music
festival this charming show uses songs
to explore friendship community and
dancing feet lullaby Lane is a unique
theoretical experience mixing the vibe
of a music gig with the intimacy of
magic and thick magic of theater handers
hen sunday the twentieth of March 2016
11 am-1 p.m. and 230 p.m. little angel
theatre recommended age to 25 years
running time
40 minutes handers hen tells the story
of Honda and her friend Aiko who go
looking for grandma's black hen Monde I
they find too fluffy blatter thighs
round the henhouse three stripy mice
under the great grain store and four
little lizards behind the pots but where
is Monde I little angel theater's
production of hand as hen uses an
over-50 specially created puppets to
bring the story to life all tickets are
four pounds and to book you can call
Roger District Council customer services
on 0170 23 18 19 one or warta govt UK /
family theatre at Rochford underscore
arts Rochford district council 2016-17
budget survey have your say local
authorities continue to face financial
challenges which mean that councils must
continue to find more innovative ways to
deliver services with much smaller
budgets whilst we are doing all that we
can to protect services the ongoing need
to make significant savings for 2016-17
and Beyond is leading to us having to
make more and more difficult decisions
and working with communities and local
organizations to protect services has
become even more important in early 2016
we will need to finalize our plans for
next year's budget to ensure that the
available funding is aligned to areas of
highest priority we would like your
views as residents businesses and
voluntary or community groups on your
priorities for council spending the
council actively works with numerous
local voluntary and community
organizations to deliver a number of
services and facilities we are keen to
hear from communities and local
organizations regarding how we can build
on this further in a dynamic way and
encourage more people to participate in
in
proving the quality of life for local
communities building long-term
resilience for individuals along with
value for money for the taxpayer please
take the opportunity to have your say by
completing the survey this will also be
available on the council's website for
online completion WWE our govt UK and
the closing date is friday the 8th of
january 2016 if you find it difficult to
complete a written survey please call
the council and they will be pleased to
help you and thank you in advance for
taking part we your views says
councillor tonik Terry cutmore leader
rochford District Council the scale of
the challenge between 2010 and 2015 we
have delivered a range of efficiencies
equating to 1.4 million pounds this
represents about ten percent reduction
to the 2010 base revenue budget of 13
point nine million pounds and has
enabled us to continue to deliver the
key services that you've told us that
you value government grants which used
to make up a significant proportion of
our income continue to be reduced there
is uncertainty about the level of
funding reductions the council will face
going forward and we will be told more
by central government over the autumn
but we are expecting those reductions to
be between 24 and forty-five percent
over the next few years up to 20 20 in
addition to the above we continue to
face inflation pressures increasing
costs and demands for public services in
order to balance the finances the
council will need to save on average
five hundred and ninety thousand pounds
per year between 2016 17 to 20 20 21
with a strong likelihood that this will
be front-loaded meaning the requirement
will be to save more of this in our
2016-17 budget focusing on the 2016-17
budget our main funding for the delivery
of our core services is expected to come
from government support grants and
council tax
circa eight point nine eight million
pounds as a comparison in 2010-11 we had
ten point six seven million pounds our
priorities our budget is designed to
deliver the core services we provide and
meet our priorities for improvement
which are set out in the business plan
2016 20 20 the plan is a living document
with its delivery plan sheduled to be
reviewed and updated annually it has not
been developed in isolation and has
taken account of national regional
countywide and local priorities the
business plan identifies the following
four themes becoming financially
self-sufficient we will pursue a range
of opportunities to generate income
including earned income from trading
activities and make the council more
self-sufficient early intervention
working closely with partners we will
use each intervention to safeguard our
young and vulnerable support new and
existing businesses manage demand on our
services and improve the outcome for our
residents maximize our assets we will
ensure that we fully utilize our assets
and create opportunities to maximize
income and generate a return on our
investments enable communities we will
engage with all parts of our communities
to encourage the most efficient and
effective mechanism for service delivery
and enable our communities to support
the delivery of services which they
consider to be important to them our
residents will be at the heart of
everything we do and we will create a
culture in the council that is focused
on real outcomes that continue to
improve our services to local
communities and enhance the difference
we make to the local economy and the
environment the main services provided
by the council recycles over sixty six
percent of the 34,000 tons of household
waste collected providing access to a
number of different leisure activities
providing and maintaining parks and open
spaces for recreational activities
providing pavilions and sports pitches
to groups and
clubs keeping our streets and pavements
clean in all weather conditions working
with police and voluntary sector in
keeping the communities safe providing
inspection regimes for food safety air
quality and noise providing planning
function in delivering planning policy
and development control providing
temporary accommodation for homeless
providing home adaptation and
improvement works for the needy
facilitates economic development spry by
providing a range of business support we
have always ensure that services valued
by our residents continue to be
delivered efficiently our approach in
response to the consistent message in
previous surveys in meeting the budget
shortfall we have sought to minimize the
impact on frontline services maximized
opportunities and focused on changing
the way we work examples of our
achievements include targeting
reductions we have reduced the number of
senior managers and reorganized our
support services greater efficiencies we
are rationalizing our offices and
supporting our staff to work flexibly
generating income we have achieved this
through a proportionate increase in fees
and charges for certain council services
and working collaboratively with other
councils sharing services in IT
procurement and payroll with the scale
of the challenges ahead this is still
not enough unfortunately given the scale
of the reductions the council has to
make in the future we may have no choice
but to make difficult decisions about
facilities and services that resident
the value it is therefore essential that
communities are willing to get involved
in helping to manage and run local
services so we need your help our
services for each of the following
services please indicate whether they
are very important neither important nor
unimportant not important or don't know
and these are recycling and waste
collection street cleansing public
conveniences accommodation for the
homeless
leisure services planning services
building control services parks and open
spaces and safeguarding and community
safety for each of following services
please indicate how satisfied you are
your choices are satisfied neither
satisfied nor dissatisfied dissatisfied
or don't know recycling on waste
collection street cleansing public
conveniences accommodation for the
homeless leisure services planning
services building control services parks
and open spaces safeguarding and
community safety if you said you are
dissatisfied with any services please
tell us why next year's council tax
increase in council tax would also help
us generate more income and help prevent
reduction in services the council did
not increase the council tax it charges
in 2015-16 a council tax freeze grant
has been received from central
government to partially compensate for
this however it is uncertain whether
this grant will be available in future
years and the level to which it will
mitigate the income that could have been
generated to sustain services provision
into the future the council may
therefore need to consider an increase
in council tax if Rochford District
Council increased its proportion of
council tax by one percent this would
raise an additional 63,000 pounds for
the council and increase the average
band d property council tax bill by
about two pounds and nine months per
year equivalent to about 4p a week 2
percent this would raise an additional
one hundred and twenty six thousand
pounds for the council and increase the
average band d property council tax bill
by about four pound eighteen pence per
year equivalent to about 8p per week
three percent this would raise an
additional one hundred and eighty nine
thousand pounds for the council and
increase the average band d property
council tax bill by about six pounds 27
per year which is equivalent to about 12
p per week
for the following three questions you
are asked to indicate yes no not sure or
not responsible for paying council tax
to rdc one would you be willing to
accept one percent increase in council
tax too would you be willing to accept a
two is in council tax three would you be
willing to accept a three percent
increase in council tax making savings
and generating income in order to
balance the finances the council will
need to save on average five hundred and
ninety thousand pounds per year between
twenty sixteen and seventeen to twenty
Twenty twenty one with a strong
likelihood that the requirement will be
to save more of this in 2016-17 budget
we have delivered a range of
efficiencies of circa 1.4 million pounds
over the last five years and need to
consider a range of opportunities for
greater efficiencies and income
generation to sustain or enhance the
quality of services if you have any
suggestions as to how the council should
save money or generate income please
tell us new ways of working the council
actively works with numerous local
voluntary and community organizations to
deliver a number of services and
facilities for example it has recently
worked with the Citizens Advice Bureau
to provide much-needed financial advice
and support to residents a number of
volunteers also assisted in the
provision of services to the community
such as Raley windmill for public events
and Rochford Housing Association
providing assistance to tenants in
completing Housing Benefit application
forms these are just a few examples
working with others in this way often
provides a number of additional benefits
to service users and can help to secure
additional external funding that the
council would simply not be entitled to
on its own we are keen to hear from
communities and local organizations
which may be interested in taking over
the running of services and assets
please answer yes
no or don't know to these two questions
would you support the idea of more of
our services being provided by voluntary
and community organizations local
communities and volunteers are you
willing to get involved in helping to
manage and run local services if you
said you are willing to be involved
please tell us how you want to be
involved if you said you're not willing
to get involved please tell us what more
the council could do to encourage you to
get involved if you have any other
comments on the council's budget please
do tell us the following questions are
optional and help us to know if we're
engaging as many different groups and
areas as possible in local
decision-making the information you
provide will be kept confidential and
processed in accordance with the Data
Protection Act 1998 your answers are
confidential and will only be used for
this consultation are you responding to
this consultation as a member of public
as a member of staff or on behalf of an
organization are you male or female what
age group are you do you have a
disability and what is your ethnicity
completed survey forms can be sent to
Rochford District Council free post CL
1858 south street rochford SS 41 be our
feedback comments by email to budget
consultation at Rochford Garvey UK and
please be clear which proposals you're
commenting on the findings of this
survey will form the draft budget
proposals for 2016-17 that will be
presented to full council in February
2016 and published on our website by the
end of februari 2016 if you are willing
to get further involved please also
provide your contact details if you
require any further information please
do not hesitate to contact the council
watch out this
Christmas are you planning for Christmas
preparing your shopping list for what
presents friends and relatives would
like remember that Christmas is also
when car thieves burglars and fraudsters
will be targeting the likes of you and
me taking the opportunity of those
unguarded moments when they can try and
flock something dodgy or relieve us of
the gifts we have saved hard for before
you go out shopping use a timer switch
give your home the lived-in look by
using timer switches on lamps a home is
less likely to be burgled if it appears
someone is home put expensive items out
of you set your burglar alarm lock all
your windows and doors lock your sheds
securely put away all the tools after
use and keep expensive equipment locked
away ensure ladders are locked away when
out shopping don't post your whereabouts
on social media and avoid using music
players and mobile phones when walking
around looking for a bargain if someone
offers you something that seems an
absolute steal it probably was don't get
caught out watch out for pickpockets
push your purse to the bottom of your
bag and zip it securely wallets should
not be in back pockets always keep alert
and aware of your surroundings
especially in busy shops and bars put
expensive items shopping bags out of
view simple things like zipping up your
bag or making sure your mobile isn't
hanging out of your back pocket makes
all the difference remember thieves are
opportunists don't give them the
opportunity don't get loaded down with
too many bags try and keep one hand free
ensure you cover your PIN when making
your purchase don't leave your bags on
the seat of your car always lock them in
the boot and keep them out of sight
after you have shopped remove shopping
and all valuable items from your car
once home store your gifts in a sensible
out of sight location EG not your garden
shed don't leave your gifts on show
after they have been opened post code
mark your presence and don't forget to
register valuable items for free on WWE
mobilize calm
out and about clubs and groups
activities at Rochford library wishing
well center every tuesday 945 to 1015 am
stories and rhymes for babies and
toddlers job club every Thursday to 2
4pm get help and advice with building
your CV and searching for work baby and
toddler group every Friday 9 30 to 10
a.m. stories and rhymes for 0 to 5 year
olds dial disability information advice
last Tuesday of every month 1030am to
130pm computer training we can help you
to start using a computer our staff for
details active life 50 + exercise
session a fun exercise session for all
abilities when and where hockley health
club Thursday's 130pm hawk will baptist
church hall fridays 930am how much four
pounds contact Oh 17025 673 274 as a
karate club our aim to promote karate in
its traditional and sport form when and
where hawk will village hall main road
hawk or Mandy's five to six pm rayleigh
primary school love lane rayleigh fried
is 3 30 to 4 30 p.m. rayleigh scout hall
london road rayleigh choose diz 6 to 7
p.m. and saturdays 10 to 11 p.m. how
much various first lessons free contact
0740 108 0078 info at forza karate calm
WWF are asif raza karate calm hockley
art group all ability levels welcome at
this small and friendly group when
thursday afternoons where the old fire
station hockley
contact colin gammon 017 0220 4706
hockley jazz record society listen to
jazz music bring your music and listen
to others programs when third thursday
of each month 732 10pm where hawk will
village hall how much three pounds each
night contact ken mizzen 0170 220 34 37
mega center youth club open youth club
sessions including paul sports games and
arts special rates on mega zone games
available during your youth club when
Mandy 615 to 745pm school years 527
Tuesday's 7pm to 9pm school years 8 plus
how much it's free contact Oh 1268 779
100 mega Center over 50 sports table
tennis badminton and short mat bowls
with a social group when Mondays
Wednesdays Thursdays to 24 p.m. how much
four pounds per person contact Oh 1268
779 100 mega plays soft play and laser
tag soft play and laser tag sessions
there are various sessions for soft play
this is one pound 26 pounds depending on
age and laser tag is 5 pounds per game
per person contacto 1268 double 7 9 10
mega staff at mega center raledo UK or
wwm egg acenta raledo UK rayleigh
library writers group a friendly group
of local writers and poets are looking
to recruit new members this is the
second thursday of each month 3 to 5
p.m. in the room two upstairs in
rayleigh library or the fourth
thursday of each month 715 to 915 please
contact us for further details this is
one pound to cover light refreshments
contact jane on 0126 878 5427 or bob
0126 878 double 496 or WR french at
talktalk dotnet Roche art group all
abilities catered for it is friendly
club with good lighting on facilities
and a variety of media this is on
Wednesday evening seven-thirty to 930 at
theresa's church hall ashington road ss4
1rf reasonable fees apply you can d
request details by contacting Deb's on
07 9077 14 double O 2 or John 079 double
3263 930 the website is WH art group
wicks WI XCOM the recycled teenagers
forum a friendly and welcoming group
providing encouragement and support for
40-plus people to access activities and
day trips at affordable prices Friday's
11 til 1145 am in the WI haul rocks with
square various prices apply contact for
membership and trip information on 0170
261 double 619 or oh double 79 220
double 724 contact recycled teenagers at
live coat UK or the website on WWE SI
called teenagers or guk committee dates
full council februari the 9th
development committee january twenty
first review committee january the fifth
and februari the second the executive
committee january the sixth and februari
the third all meetings will take place
at the civic sweet to hockley road rail
ESS 680 be starting at seven thirty p.m.
for information call member services on
0 1 702
318 140 nominate your citizen of the
year do you know a person or group in
the Rockford district that has made a
huge difference to the community have
you ever thought to yourself they should
get an award for what they do if you
have this is your chance to nominate
them for an award from helping neighbors
to tirelessly working in the community
the chairman of Rochford district
council counselor mrs. Heather Glynn
wants to hear about these extraordinary
people and groups they may never ask or
expect any credit for what they do but
they truly deserve recognition in this
year's Rochford District Citizen of the
Year awards the council runs the awards
to recognize and acknowledge people and
groups in the district for their
valuable work or outstanding
achievements the awards are designed to
honor those who may not normally be
recognized for their efforts nominations
are open to individuals and groups
within the Rockford district entries
will be judged by the Chairman who will
elect winners in three categories an
overall winner will also be selected
from the three category winners and the
categories are achievement of the year
an individual of any group who lives in
the district charitable group groups of
all ages youth group groups for those
aged under 18 years nominees will be
invited to attend the Citizen of the
Year awards in April where the winners
will be presented with their award by
the Chairman to enter complete the
nomination form or email civic officer
at Rochford dot Garvey UK to obtain an
electronic version if you find this
difficult please contact the council who
will be pleased to help you all
nominations must be received by the 31st
of January 2016 the decision of the
Chairman is final please return your
completed nomination form to the Civic
officer raat to a district council South
Street Rochford Essex ss4 1bw and don't
forget nominees must reside in the
district of Rochford
Sports Awards 2015 the 2015 Rochford
District Council and Castle Point
Borough Council sports award sponsored
by a fusion lifestyle took place on
thursday the 12th of november with
cricket legend Ronnie Ronnie invited to
present the winners and with their
awards the winners in each category are
four Rochford district council club of
the year sponsored by pinnacle PSG
winner rochford running club runner-up
east essex triathlon club school of the
year sponsored by affinity 1777 winner
Holt farm infant school two runners-up
Fitz why mark school and the West rings
primary academy services to sport
respect award sponsored by the
co-operative funeralcare winner richard
harrison for his services to cricket
runner-up core team hockley woods park
run rochford district council Chairman's
Award winner was Rebecca Terry
disability sports personality of the
year sponsored by waters and Stanton
limited the winner was Lucy Hodges for
sailing two runners-up Matthew Alton and
Kiara tap ndon for swimming young sports
personality of the year sponsored by
south in united community and
educational trust winner Christian brown
athletics two runners-up Olivia King for
tennis and Laura runciman for athletics
sports personality of the year award
sponsored by Wells legal solicitors
winner was Taylor Carter for golf and
runner-up was Christian Brown athletics
and castle point sponsored by a pinnacle
PSG club of the year winner hadley
mountain bike club two runners-up castle
point joggers and porters sock ability
football club school of the year
sponsored by affinity 1777 winner was
the danes school two runners-up kensal
infants academy and thundersley primary
school services to sport respect award
sponsored by the co-operative
funeralcare winner nigel Stewart
football and runner-up Naomi palea
swimming castlepoint Borough Council
mayor's award winner Abby
language disability sports personality
of the year sponsored by waters and
Stanton limited winner James right for
swimming runner-up Matthew Hamilton for
athletics young sports personality of
the year sponsored by southend united
community and educational trust winner
laura been archery and two runners-up
alex body for archery and hayden skinner
for gymnastics sports personality of the
year sponsored by worlds legal
solicitors winner was to lead ethan
football basketball and athletics lauren
ban archery stay well this winter now's
the time to get your free flu jab this
week all those it at risk groups are
being reminded to get their free flu jab
adults over 65 those with long-term
health conditions children aged two to
seven carers and pregnant women may all
be eligible the reminder is being issued
by NHS England public health England the
Department of Health the NHS trust
development agency and monitor every
year hundreds of thousands of people see
their GPS and tens of thousands are
hospitalized because of flu symptoms of
flu can be very unpleasant and last for
several weeks it can lead to more
serious complications like middle ear
infections in children and pneumonia or
bronchitis for those with underlying
health conditions and in some cases it
can be fatal Trisha Dorsey chief nurse
at NHS castle point and Rochford
clinical commissioning group CCG said
flu is a highly contagious illness that
spreads rapidly through population it
can cause serious complications for
at-risk groups such as the elderly
expectant mothers and people with
long-term health conditions this year
more children are being vaccinated
because we know that they can be very
easily picked up germs and spread them
amongst friends and family members this
vaccination program helps protect the
population tritiated my advice for
anyone eligible for the free flu
vaccination is to get
now before flu starts to circulate in
the community although it is not
possible to know which strains of flu
will circulate each winter the flu
vaccination is still the best protection
against an unpredictable virus which can
cause severe illness and deaths amongst
vulnerable groups throughout the last
decade there has generally been a good
match between the strains of flu in the
vaccine and those that subsequently
circulate so it's important that we do
all we can to ensure venerable people
are not discouraged from having flu
vaccinations now or in the future
vaccines are available between October
2015 and March 2016 says contact your
local GP or pharmacy now it's free
because you need it for more information
visit www.fema.gov the year in the
National primary care awards 2015 dr.
Roger Luke Gardner ccg governing body
member and local GP chief nurse Trisha
Dawson Debbie Vic head of financial
management and planning attended the
complimentary awards ceremony that took
place in London on 8th of October the
award was presented by Julie would chief
executive of NHS clinical commissioners
criteria for the award included evidence
of great leadership with both clinical
and managerial leadership seen
throughout the organization and
successfully navigation through
performance quality improvement and
financial pressures the CCG was
recognized for having a golden thread
through its strategic and operational
plans to demonstrate how it is focusing
on local patient and population needs
and service transformation to improve
local health outcomes the CCG was
nominated for its pioneering preventive
care coordinations service that delivers
care to
more vulnerable patients in Castle Point
and Rochford who may be at risk of
decline the award celebrated CCGs who
have gone the extra mile with respect to
integrated working moving away from the
archaic model of working individually
working in partnership with GP practices
the new service will identify those
patients whose health they deemed to be
at risk of decline predominantly the
frail elderly and those with long term
conditions instead ssin accountable
officer for NHS castlepoint and rockford
ccg said this is truly fantastic news we
have something special here at the
castle point and Rochford ccg a great
mix of clinical leaders and managers who
are truly passionate about improving the
health and well-being of our local
community we are also lucky to have
great relationships with all of our
partners including those delivering
local services the voluntary sector and
local authorities we look forward to
building on this with mutual aims to
make things better for local residents
Rochford district matters is designed
and published by Rochford District
Council the telephone number for the
council is 0 1 702 546 366 and this
recording has been produced by
volunteers from the rayleigh Rochford
and castle point talking newspaper